valérie j'ai une petite fille une petite
image vous ce matin cyril vous avez été
interviewé par anne roumanoff sur europe
1 que j'adore sur europe 1 avec à une
bande formidable on va parler ce que
vous étiez très en forme
visiblement vous connaissez très bien
les chroniqueurs qui constitue sa bande
bah oui oh oui regardez choix fondé la
pompe charrier brabo a les balles itar
tass
on a eu un retour dans cette émission à
quelques semaines qui a animé aussi une
émission de chez lui nous a dit que
plusieurs c'était de faire en sorte de
cacher à la fois sa calvitie et son
double menton
est-ce que vous aussi c'est votre cas
malheureusement il a pas plus que moi
[Rires]
alors si la nuda là vous reprenez les
missions à prendre ou à laisser
c'est un rêve de prendre sa démission
alors qu'est vraiment un rêve pour moi
c'est mon joueur préféré est question
pour un champion tu pleurais et 80 en
questions pour un champion tu repars
avec deux encyclopédies choisir des
boîtes turban avec 250 milles au quoi tu
te rappelles ben appel comme il veut il
m'appelle comme il veut on a constaté
cyril hanouna que la découpe s'améliorer
parce que moi j'ai regardé votre
émission au début et c'était pas
terrible
franchement j'avais été le bac au début
sur le canapé akale tapis en début du
magnifique étude crédite il n'a pas
plongé tout enlever et j'ai décidé de
faire un tuto que terry en fait dans mon
salon empêcher battu l'avez remarqué
mais c'était mieux après pas plaisir aux
gens se mélangent les gens se
plaignaient j'aurais dit oh les mecs
merci anne roumanoff en tout cas on
s'est bien marré avec toute sa bande
et franchement ils sont formidables tous
les matins anne roumanoff sur europe 1
qui cartonne et elle le mérite
alors et j'ai un rêve qui se réalise
pour moi lundi matin parce que j'ai mon
animateurs un de mes animateurs radio
préférée 6 des poumons animateurs
préférés et j'aime beaucoup couru mais
j'aime également énormément disney et
pour moi voilà le plus grand animal
heures radio de tous les temps qui m'a
proposé de venir faire le morning avec
lui de 6h à 9h lundi sur skyrock je suis
comme un ouf avec toute sa bande bien
sûr et je vais faire tout le morning
avec eux il y en a que trois qui l'ont
fait il m'avait dit je croise et soprano
j + qui voilà deux gars qui aime bien il
m'a dit voilà et j'étais comme un fou
donc merci des foules merci skyrock et
je serai donc sur skyrock de 6h à 9h
pour faire le morning avec eux on va
préparer des trucs de ouf on en sera
leur adversaire n'aura du coup je serai
bosse en tout cas quoi je serai devant
le poste j'ai l'accord enfin vous vous
réveillerez vous rentrerez de boîte de
nuit en boîte de nuit donc une boîte de
nuit chez lui